stars and then it will be in Evancho's
heart no he develops tonight got that
wrong yeah but it's still flexible it
could still transpose as you mentioned
Ivanka to some of his favorite openings
so it's a what we call the symmetrical
English now white did develop with his
Knight normally this is called the reti
but uh due to the push of both sides C
pawns
um it has transposed to that English
opening and now white has a choice white
can push a pawn in the center of the
board where I can bring his other Knight
out from the queen side
black is just going to free and Kettle
his Bishop to a dark Square we might see
what we call the accelerated dragon
and we've transposed into that opening
now after a trade of Pawns in the center
White's night coming out white has these
two Pawns in the middle of the board on
the light squares this creates a maroxy
bind and any type of bind in chess makes
it hard for the opponent to break out we
see a set of knights disappearing
everything's balanced but white has a
bit more space in the center with his
pawns solid start by both sides no
aggressive attack yet but it doesn't
have that great a reputation maybe for
black yeah absolutely set up I would
have thought the girlfriend would be
very happy with the way this is gone
where you know your van could mention
that girl fan maybe prefers a positional
game and he's got this moroxy bind as
you mentioned which is uh it gives white
space Advantage it's a bit easier for
white to play and black can get a little
bit passive here and we know that
Chucky's main strength is like you know
if he can unbalance the position and
it's a long way at this position from
becoming unbalanced so I I would say
Ivanka that you know white be happy the
way this opening is gone yeah I agree
you know take a look at what's porn in
the Pawns in the middle both of them
control a lot of squares they specially
control any breakouts that black might
plan with the pawns and it's just now
about developing the pieces and just
sitting on that extra space and what
you're going to see instead is that if
evanchook has to mix things up at some
point he has to break out
yeah this opening is regarded as quite
passive for black but I have noticed uh
it's been trendy in recent years there
are chessable courses now on the
accelerated dragon and black is actually
the one choosing this variation in a way
you can kind of just play the next few
moves on autopilus as black Black's
Bishop has just developed next one of
Black's Rooks is going to come to the C
file you might push a pawn in a certain
way and Black's plan is very
straightforward there's nothing to
memorize so there are things that speak
in favor of this opening Choice
Adventure clearly knows what's going on
he knows everything about everything
pretty much in the opening
but girlfriend meanwhile it's frowning
slightly he looks a bit surprised and
just picking his uh picking his move
here White's light Squad Bishop is
likely to develop
imagine get imagine like burrowing
evanchuk's brain mind for like half an
hour or something you know like she's
exhausted oh you'd be you'd have to have
a lay down for at least at least a year
afterwards wouldn't you but I mean just
jumping in to to all those variations
that he's he's uh probably memorized
over his lifetime all those games he's
memorized all that just pure information
it must be incredible you know his
knowledge and obviously girl found as
well
um but you know we can see from his
analysis the way he thinks is just
exceptional
um so yeah I mean going back to the game
I I was wondering if white can somehow
you know move in the bishop Castle looks
very sensible but you can also maybe try
putting the knight in the middle at some
point maybe going uh playing a poor move
and then throwing that in and it kind of
depends I mean if if white can stabilize
you would have thought maybe white is
more comfortable still here uh just
because of the space Advantage is easier
to play with spacevantage that's that's
a pretty little pyramid that you've
created there David as well I like it
that night at the top of the pyramid the
old Capstone up there lovely stuff David
you know we like our David knows his uh
history as well as his theory because
I'm just checking the database and you
can you guess
who were the two world champions who
played against this particular position
against each other the two world
champions yeah and I think old ones oh
god
um
I'll go give you a king patraction and
then the Mad one Tau no although he's a
magician the magician the Mad one was
the one that we all celebrating Fisher
yeah
right okay fish have played Black yeah
and the result was
ah okay no surprise there and uh Ivanka
in this I mean this game is actually
following that one as far as I know and
uh did White Knight did the white knight
jump in there it did it did and uh maybe
you can take us through what happened in
that game because we know Evancho he's a
great chess historian as well he will be
aware of that game for sure girlfriend
maybe less so yeah but there was a
slight difference but okay the bishop
wasn't here the bishop was on E2 and uh
the black porn moved to A6 uh okay so
there was there were these two moves
flicked in and then the Knight came in
and because the game ended in draw there
was a series of mass exchanges
everything got swapped off the Queens
came off first and then the night came
off and then I love the way I also love
the way you say the Mad one I was just
like the Mad one it's just like I was
like oh there's so many mad chess
players on it but okay anyway
yeah it was he actually captured with
the other call David yeah and uh and by
the way white gets a nice kind of
Connect Four yeah and a bit more space
so I can put a bishop on this Square
yeah and uh yeah it looks pretty
balanced but white is maybe having a bit
more fun instead girlfriend brought his
Bishop to this Square so we could see
similar still yeah if for example black
pushes the pawn White's Knight might
jump in and we might see that trade of
Queens
Let's uh go back to the players this one
still very very tense you mentioned uh
evanchook's memory Simon that you know
there must be so much knowledge inside
his Adam Peter heiner Nelson the coach
of Magnus Carlsen tweeted uh right now
that Evancho has been quoted saying why
do I need a database of millions of
games I can only remember Ten Thousand
it's like 9999 more than most people can
remember exactly is he known for that
his memory just like Magnus Carlsen is
known for his exceptional memory
yeah I mean I guess you can't stay at
the top of World Chess unless you have
some phenomenal talents and with the
ventric it's probably memory it's
creativity it's
um calculation as well a few things but
yeah I mean the top plays in the world
I'm not sure how much they train it but
they do train the memory a bit and
obviously it helps to have some natural
capacity in that regard
um I know kramnik said he played through
10 000 games every month just in case
there were new ideas uh I don't know how
he remembers this new ideas when they
come up but Magnus of course it's like a
sponge his brain it all soaks up and
goes in yeah and uh black indeed pushes
the a pawn forward and perhaps prepares
a break on the left and uh well Kaya
mentioned a tweet and today is going to
be a really dramatic day I mean it's
going to be so much excitement on and
potentially off the board and of course
we love it when you're at home join in
and all the fun and action and send us a
tweet using the hashtag chess Champs so
send us your selfies your pictures your
thoughts uh what do you think is going
to happen who you're cheering for we
love to hear everything you guys post
and of course we will try and feature
them on the show yeah yeah definitely
want to hear your thoughts today before
that big dramatic game especially
between Magnus and Hans in the next
round round six in the Julius bird
generation cup
yeah this feels like the Calm before the
storm fan just uh deciding if he doesn't
jump into the center with his Knight if
he decides to keep Queens on the board
instead then maybe there's more chances
for both sides to imbalance things but
um I think it would just be sensible
here for girlfriend to jump into the
center with this Knight it takes most of
the risk out the position if the Queens
disappear and for gelfand after a tough
start yesterday losing uh losing his
games there I think it's just quite a
pleasant situation where you can kind of
try for an advantage with minimal risk
what do you think Simon I totally agree
yeah I mean with with the last move
black is really telegraphing his
intentions and if black gets one more
move um he he has possibility to break
out and you've really got to watch out
for your your opponent's uh breakouts
especially when you've got the more
space and you don't really want to allow
ever your opponent getting any counter
play with some Pawn break why I mean
even even if it's like not always a
great break you're just like I don't
want to calculate it so if I was white
here I would just be throwing that
Knight into the middle I can't be worse
I'm going to have a space Advantage okay
I might not win the game but I certainly
can't lose the game uh if I exchange
queens and just keep it very simple so
this would be I think a very very
obvious move to play and to my eyes it
looks like white should certainly have a
small advantage and uh as you're
demonstrating ensuring middle game just
because he's got space advantage and you
know this bishop that you showed there
David is beautiful uh open E file it
looks really Pleasant for white actually
I mean I I realized I've allowed a check
here I'd have to retreat but yeah I mean
this type of thing at least yeah and you
can make an argument for at some point
trying to push this Pawn forward and try
to clamp down as long as you stop
Black's break and maybe black is still
breaking I mean you could take the other
Pawn if you really wanted to play doubly
safe uh in in this one so you okay
symmetrical meaning more of a drawing
chance but you take out any risk
whatsoever by by playing in this manner
and he's played it so he has that Pro
logical and uh incidentally
um this position was actually not this
night jump but the position had been
played before by two other world
champions this time if I give you a one
word clue okay go for it okay Legend
there's one Gary Gary Gary was playing
with the white pieces and then I'm going
to say the trainer
trainer trainer yeah
it's close but uh okay think modern day
trainer modern day trainer the one who
got divorced recently when he got
divorce recently yeah
I'm sorry
that's a famous interview right where he
said it felt like a divorce yeah when
the coaching student broke up uh-huh
right but uh meanwhile he imagined
taking the risk out of this position
they're taking all the Rooks out of this
position yeah
girlfriend here just trying to
kind of speed up that process into the
end game it makes sense here girlfriend
is a great endgame player um I talked
about him in that grind like a
Grandmaster course as one of the kind of
Inspirations for the grinding technique
where you take the risk out first then
you look for small advantages you build
up and you don't necessarily write off
the game as a draw you just keep trying
to squeeze and looking for opportunities
so he's done that he's removed all risk
what the reason I choose white here just
a little bit more space in the center
white has a really nice Pawn structure
there but it's going to be difficult to
break through the Bishops will just
cancel each other out can can a the
white king try to get in on the fun so I
mean the way that I I would be thinking
is that that white king belongs on the
left you know primarily on the B6 Square
you know let's put it all the way up
there and the only way it can cross that
river is to um just swap off dark Square
Bishops so one thing I would be thinking
is David's highlight step up the king
use the bishop the dark Square Bishop as
a bridge and uh try to dash across but I
realize this takes a lot of time yeah
and unless the black king might come as
well too yeah hold the foot if Black's
King was on the wrong side of the board
you're right Ivanka yeah and then this
would be a killer plan just walk in and
start grabbing everything but
yeah unfortunately it does look like the
black king is quick enough to kind of
March over
and uh yeah after we see a bunch of
exchanges
it might just get completely blocked off
that being said it's a bit awkward for
black Black's King is stuck kind of
defending the entry point for the white
king
what do we think here just draw
probably probably just a dry I don't
know how you break this down I mean even
if you need to pull and push in these
positions to try and uh get you know
open up another way in but I can't see
any pawn push that will really help and
why why should white be winning these
positions black has no weaknesses at all
he's super solid so we've correct played
this position as a draw yeah you kind of
need a knight here for white uh to start
kind of jumping in if you could imagine
a knight jumping into this Square
starting to attack some some pawns but
as you said if you don't have a knight
you can't Target anything and for
example this is a weakness but the white
Bishop is doing nothing if it sits there
the white king can't really get there so
sometimes the squares the weaknesses
they're only as weak as the pieces that
remain I think you have to try a pawn
break I mean maybe you can use Barry you
know or or try to do some space gaining
on the other side but you're kind of you
know kind of hoping really aren't you to
that your opponent's going to make an
error uh and Chucky hasn't been making
many errors so far yeah it just looks
like a really respectful game from both
sides neither of them really uh kind of
going on the offensive yet but still
some life uh left can either side
squeeze the other yeah that's the
question right now
looks like a quite calm round so far
this round five in the tournament bars
on the bottom of the screen roughly to
the middle in most games but I am
noticing uh in the game between the two
19 year olds are you guys see and Neiman
it looks very good for the young Indian
bar all the way over to his side could
be a very bad start to the day for Hans
Neiman before that big battle against
Magnus Carlsen and after uh only 15
minutes as well something must have gone
horribly wrong for me mom yeah I'm just
taking a look at that game it feels like
he's played a bit too quickly um
Neiman's been playing very fast this
tournament and it's worked well for him
but
um he blundered a pawn to quite a
typical kind of tactic uh early in that
game so Neiman maybe he's just got his
eyes his focus on that match against
Magnus and uh yeah difficult start for
him so far today
yeah it must be difficult for hands
actually and Magnus knowing that the
eyes of the world are on them yeah and
that everybody and I've had lots of
messages actually from Friends saying
hey you know what's happening in the
Chess World and uh it's not going to be
just test players it's going to be
everyone and the media of course it's a
lot for one set of shoulders right to
Curry yeah imagine nimon 19 year old you
know either
he has cheated the the allegations are
true a huge Scandal or he hasn't and he
has to stand In This Storm with these
allegations it's just massive Scandal I
mean he's either the villain or he's a
victim right and he's a victim of uh
yeah I mean what could be career
damaging uh yeah I mean insinuations and
yeah it's I can't imagine what he's
going through it must have been so
difficult for him to continue playing a
tournament last week and then to come
here play again immediately face the
world champion but uh I mean I think you
know I I think if he does deal with it
if he can deal with it it's actually
gonna he's gonna come out stronger and
it will actually help him you know if he
can just get through it and you know and
everything is the way you know he does
become innocently he's innocent whatever
it is it's very odd
um if he comes through the toughness
then you know he's gonna I think it will
really help him actually because he's
gonna have this Limelight you know he's
he's going to have potential business
opportunities and he it's proven that
he's you can beat some of the best
players in the world so uh so it's like
yeah these tough times it's like in life
you know you just like you have to get
through them don't you so you know and
you know again you know I don't know
what's going on Magnus as well he's
probably he's getting this you know who
knows what's happening there as well so
it's it's it's very uh it's a very
strange situation that's all I can say
yeah so yeah and I have to say it you
know from what I've seen on Twitter
there is a lot of support for Hans
Neiman uh a lot of people saying that
they cannot find any proof of cheating
in that game in St Louis but I guess the
Chess World as well is divided in this
matter it tends to be two extremes as
well it's kind of people who are fully
on the side of Neiman asking for the
proof and rightly so I mean if there's
no proof you can't accuse people but
there's also people on the other side
who are willing to condemn without any
evidence and
um It's Tricky there's a huge divide
right now and I mean for example some of
the games even yesterday on the tour I
mean it's utter genius some of the moves
he's coming up with and
um again I mean people can come up with
all sorts of explanations for that but I
mean if he is innocent we're witnessing
one of the greatest talents in chess uh
ever so
um yeah I mean It's just tough time
emotional day for both these two players
and I guess there will be a Fallout as
well yeah ah wow and uh
40 minutes approximately that game will
start we are all looking forward to that
in the meantime we are enjoying a game
between these two legends but the bar is
[Laughter]
maybe maybe they got their beads in
yeah
just joking it's objectively a draw I
guess a best play with correct play yeah
and uh I mean there have been some
changes a couple of Pawns disappeared
the light Squad Bishops got exchanged
but yeah this one both sides just
running out of material essentially and
I think I'd still choose white just
because white should have the better
Bishop black spawn in the center the
black d Pawn not ideally placed I like
how whites put pawns on light squares
his Bishops on dark squares that's just
kind of good coordination and of course
girlfriend is fantastic uh with those
positional factors
but uh yeah it's going to be hard to
break through if girlfriend wants to win
we should mention now then it's a
critical moment he needs to take with
his F Pawn normally if you have a choice
of two different pawns to capture with
you want to capture towards the center I
would say 90 of the time because you
control more squares if you have Rooks
on the board then kind of clearing the
clearing the open files on the edge
they're really helpful but okay I think
he's happy to go for the draw here he
does capture towards the center which is
uh typical and natural but if you're
taking the other way at least there was
a chance to create a past pawn and
balance things slightly I think they've
got they got so much respect for each
other as well and when you played
someone literally for your whole
lifetime and you know you you know how
good they are and you're here and you've
got all these youngsters ready it's like
okay you're kind of like you want to go
you want to go easy on your fellow
grandfather you know so you just need to
take easy you know like I don't mean
that in a bad way but compared to the
other players they are the grandfathers
it's like me compared to David I'm the
grandfather I'm the grandfather at a
table
um kind of yeah Daddy William
Bring it on I am the Grand Daddy
are you reading this tree from Ollie
Peterson
oh dear Dad his dad in an ideal world is
it David the Brother Kyle the little
sister oh thank you oh thank you thank
you Oliver Peterson and Ivanka what is
it girlfriend
so I am your daddy
oh gosh
oh
yeah get rid of that sweet now
by the way these uh these two Elder
Statesmen of the game the more
experienced players
um still just keeping the balance not
too much changing here I do like what
girlfriend's doing with his pawns just
aesthetically it looks so nice for white
but there's no breakthrough no way to
create a passport no way to kind of
trade off the Bishops in a favorable
kind of transition towards the
King opponent game just
no way to do anything essentially
yesterday uh Simon you uh noticed the
books behind Ivan Shook and I just
wanted to mention before this game ends
if it ends quite fast look at all the
trophies Behind These two that is a
lifetime of success yeah massive
and I've heard that Champions by just
displaying their Trophies by seeing them
every day they kind of get in that
winning mentality so maybe that's
something I should do as others should
do if you have trophies display them
Inspire yourself remind yourself that
you are a winner that's where I've gone
wrong
I remember I uh so I made the the story
on Magnus carlsen's World Championship
uh era and I visited his father and all
the world championship trophies was
there in this cabinet in the corner like
the trophies was like bottom shelf
nothing magnets saw every day because
obviously he doesn't live there so uh
maybe he should listen to this yeah it's
interesting um I know younger players
they like to display their trophies as
well just as a bunch of Pride but I
think the older players they do it for
the memories and David you know you know
you well famously won the gold medal at
the Olympiad why didn't you wear that
like you know like a Beastie Boy like
you know someone go around the
nightclubs
you know wear that gold out you can feel
that you know I think it's pretty good
get that mentality yeah I've got
imposter syndrome anytime I put it on
I'm like do I deserve this is this is
this really it's not real gold
unfortunately but yeah it's uh I think
you need to wear it more maybe I should
I think you need to rock it out more
definitely for my birthday I'll bring it
up oh yeah
do you have it displayed or in a drawer
um it's in a box somewhere in the flat
and still and it's kind of protective
case to bring it out we'll see the world
show the world yeah and yeah I mean that
not just displaying the trophies that
they're proud of but also those chess
books I think that's I mean the mountain
of their knowledge clearly I still
recommend the old school way of doing it
read those books
useful useful aid but meanwhile White's
Bishop slightly improved flux Bishop
flexible
no targets for the black Bishop just
hitting thinner there's literally
nothing it can attack on dark squares
other than its fellow Bishop
yeah these players keeping us guessing
but this one is going to be a draw a
barring
just Madness from either of the two
players yeah and uh yeah plenty of time
on left on the clock for both as well
yeah I mean I can't say I I blame uh
Boris for playing very solidly um I
think it was the tournament situation
yesterday he had a bit of a horrible day
as he said so himself and he lost all
his games so when you you're in that
situation you kind of want to study the
ship you just want to get one half Point
somewhere and then that kind of resets
those previous losses and then you can
begin again and uh just get playing and
whilst the players are thinking not that
much happening well GM rsim sends us a
selfie of his wife playing chess
although so he does say it looks like
she doesn't care about her King come on
Castle now it's always a good idea to
Castle yeah and unless unless I'm just
thinking about someone who doesn't
Castle who was the one that doesn't
Castle oh we had one tournament where it
was a Prague someone was not castling
yeah probably I mean Magnus likes to to
delete it as long as possible Prague
maybe yeah I've been in trouble myself
in games where I've forgotten to Castle
yeah no I think it was Prague might have
been the last tournament in Miami it was
like yeah I remember there was something
going on and I was like why are they not
castling I wanted in a tournament where
I got well not a tournament but a team
event and I just didn't Castle I was
doing everything other than castling and
I went on my games that's why I said oh
that is the secret to chess don't Castle
but no that comes with a don't try this
at home
um yeah yeah wisdom is with castle by
move 12 then uh oh it's getting safe
that's why I heard when I was young at
least ah Magnus has a rule himself when
it comes to castling you know he says
one move if your king is one move away
from castling then your king is pretty
safe if it's two moves from castling uh
maybe safe maybe not safe okay if it's
three moves away from casting aha you've
got to worry about your king because I
could get under attack quite quite
quickly huh
meanwhile the vacuum cleaner is out in
this game all the queen side pawns or
the left half of the board and they've
all been eliminated exchanged off
um yeah just no breakthrough
no material left no passports it's
difficult to get excited about this
position as Ivanka said completely
understandable result actually quite
good for both players gelfand is now
going to be off the mark in the
tournament he's going to gain a bit of
momentum if antrik meanwhile he's well
placed for those uh kind of top eight
those knockout spots yeah I'm gonna be
really valuable I expect they might even
repeat Bishop moves now David don't you
and like just uh you know there's
there's nothing here that can happen
there really isn't I mean uh you know
it's here we go they might just yep I
think they're repeating Bishop maze they
know it's a dead draw so it looks like
uh we're getting that draw yeah it's the
draw between our two legends uh the
first point in the tournament for Boris
galfont and another point for Evancho KU
is on fire in this tournament so